first up though chief White House
correspondent John Roberts on which way
the wind may be blowing tonight when it
comes to the Muller Russian probe good
evening John bracket evening to you the
president has said on several occasions
that he would like to sit down for an
interview with Robert Muller
but the chances of that happening
according to people we've talked to are
rapidly approaching zero
multiple sources tell Fox News that
President Trump and his outside legal
team are expected to say no to an
interview with Robert Miller hit a phone
call to Fox News earlier today attorney
Rudy Giuliani certainly appeared to
indicate that I'm no sit down until
until we get we get ironed out exactly
what they want to do right now I'm
telling him no way president Trump has
gotten markedly more personal in his
criticism of the Moller investigation
tweeting about Muller's alleged
conflicts of interest including the fact
that we had a very nasty and contentious
business relationship that appears to be
a reference to a purported 2011 dispute
over fees at the Trump golf course
outside Washington while the decision is
not yet final and the President does
have the ultimate say sources familiar
with the investigation tell Fox News the
president's team does not believe Muller
has made a compelling case for an
interview that he has not proven only
the president possesses the information
he needs the swirl of scandal around the
genesis of the Russia investigation also
helped seal the deal thank you very much
at an East Room news conference with
Italy's Prime Minister today President
Trump wasn't asked about the Moller
interview or the other hot topic of the
day his legal team's vilification of
attorney michael cohen for taping a
conversation with the president about a
possible payoff to a playboy model there
are innumerable other recordings of
other people having nothing to do with
the Trump the Trump the Trump
Organization which will give you an idea
what it what it whatis counsel II was my
opinion of him has turned on a dime when
I found out he was a lawyer recording
his client well fundamentally that's a
diss barbel offense but at the news
conference the president did expand on
his threat to shut down the government
if Congress won't give him what he wants
on immigration reform and 25 billion
dollars to build a wall along the
southern border I would be certainly
willing to consider a shutdown if we
don't get proper border security
I have no red line the president was
unfriendly territory on the issue of
immigration Italy's Prime Minister has
pledged to tighten his country's
immigration
laws but avoiding the political fallout
from a government shutdown may be a
difficult maneuver for President Trump
to accomplish
president Trump also surprised the
nation today
a week after threatening Iran with
consequences the likes of which few
throughout history have ever suffered
the president said he would be willing
to sit down and talk with Iranian
president Hassan rouhani I'll meet with
anybody
I believe in meeting do you have
preconditions for that meeting no
preconditions no they want to meet only
anytime they want anytime they want it's
good for the country good for them good
for us and good for the world
president Trump and Prime Minister Conte
also agreed on the need to improve
relations with Russia Conti saying that
Russia is involved in almost every
crisis around the world the two did part
company though to some degree on
sanctions President Trump wanted to keep
sanctions on Russia Conti wanting to
review them but saying they will stay on
for now Brett good to have you back John
on soggy North Lawn tonight Thanks